yeah but i mean it's it'll be
interesting to see what happens in this
next year because every every other
country seems to be getting their
vaccines and we are
still like we're probably not going to
be able to get our vaccines this year if
we stay in japan it's right looking more
and more likely but i mean you know
there's like
i know of a few of my american friends
who are here who are just
probably just going to like bite the
bullet and just go back to america the
same time this year to just go get the
whole
yeah everyone like my age in america is
already getting it yeah yeah exactly in
the uk as well yeah uk as well yeah
being a kid again when they always got
the games before you [ __ ] man i'm like
why are you all getting the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] it's reversed now
like yeah it's the last one
exactly like japan was always the first
now you're the last
i feel like i've been lied to but like
are you guys gonna do it i'm probably
going to do it i mean i don't blame you
i'll [ __ ] do it
like if i was an american or like or
from the uk i would absolutely it's
twofold for me right because i
i want to go to the uk i want to go back
to uk yeah
my friends toast goddamn it you know
it's it's been like this is i think this
is the longest i've been from like
seeing my family
yeah see my friend yeah so i'm just like
that's that
that and the vaccine if i can get
everything done in one trip then that's
yeah i'm gonna take like a month and a
half off
japan and just go do the things that i
want
i need to do for my health and also
catch up to all the things like
beans and toast in it just want to have
it it's just want to have something [ __ ]
my friends just beans
there's no heinz beans here what the
[ __ ] am i supposed to do like
see the problem was [ __ ] depressing i
legitimately
i legitimately miss beans and toast i'm
sorry i i crave it
i don't think there's a more depressing
sight than just beans and toast by
itself i'm sorry
tastes good as a brit like seeing the
sight of just like beans on toast as
like a [ __ ]
breakfast dinner whatever that's
fantastic see i feel that way but like
two or three times a year i just wake up
and i'm like [ __ ] go for some
beans right now baked beans heinz baked
beans i'm like
great source of protein as well yeah i
mean like what's not to like
[ __ ] me up beans are magical they're
like [ __ ] fantastic make me fart like
a [ __ ] but who cares it's still
good
who cares i like that yeah it feels like
you're being cleansed
it's like detoxing but like that's the
problem right it's like at least you
guys and like all my american friends
have
you know a choice to do that right yeah
go back it's you know doubly like get it
back
like australia apparently made it
illegal to return if you're from india
right
if you're yeah oh really i think a lot
of
well that's the problem right is that
like i can't do the same for australia
because we're in no rush to get the
vaccine because no one's had covert for
the past four months
so like not even my grandma who's like
92 this year has gotten it yet
yeah it's like late maybe like you got
you guys are isolated as [ __ ] it's like
it's hard enough to get in your country
as it is
exactly yeah i mean it makes sense right
but like you know that's why australia's
done so well
and same with new zealand but yeah
that's like the whole world goes through
like the [ __ ] apocalypse australia's
just gonna be australia and new zealand
are gonna be like the two remaining
countries
exactly right nothing goes in nothing
comes out man
seeing the whole like uh like the whole
joe rogan controversy about all the like
vaccines and stuff
yeah it's it's so frustrating that like
it's literally
been the only thing anyone can talk
about for the past like year and a half
is
covered and all this [ __ ] yeah but it's
also like saying that you can't talk
about because everyone's [ __ ] turned
it into a political thing
yeah well it's just like i just i just
want to eat baked beans i just don't
want to die
i just i just don't want to be ill and i
don't want to get other people ill yeah
i didn't i didn't know it's become like
a thing like that like even now talking
about it i feel like
[ __ ] there's probably like some [ __ ]
[ __ ] in the comments who are like
annoyed about it i was talking about i
just want to kiss my homies good night
man
exactly come on man let me kiss my
homies [ __ ] out
i just want to eat some [ __ ] baked
beans watch cars 2 in the theater you
know
i mean what wasn't it like the uk
recently i think like couple of days ago
just had their first muscular mask
mask-less concert it was like 5 000
people at a concert or something and
there were none of them wearing musk
because they were all vaccinated i'm not
sure about
melin can you like check checkers
but like i'm not surprised either
because the uk has been
i mean the us and the uk have been so
[ __ ] good with their vaccines
i loved how uh in the uk when they
literally were like okay guys i
think you can maybe go out for drinks
now yeah like the first day
london was like rammed and it was
children of course it would be and they
were like
like 10 years for this we're going to go
to the point with jerry it's like oh my
god
exactly go i can't i can't imagine how
weather spoons was going to be like as
soon as they opened up oh my god
i do miss a good weather spoons actually
you know the government could tell
like if britain had to fight in like
another war you know and the government
was like please fight please fight for
us and they'd be like nah nah they're
like
pubs will be open if you fight they'll
be like where are we fighting where are
we fighting
i don't know what it is about pubs and
british people but like it it turns them
into something it's
like ferocious like when pubs come into
the equation yeah they become like
different people yeah they're like
so you suddenly become more passionate
yeah i
i feel like people in britain weren't
taking like the
pandemic seriously until pub started
closing down yeah and that's that's like
the real
end of the world they're like i sleep i
can't go to school or work whatever
whatever
i can't believe these politicians have
done this oh
the amount of clubs with like 16 and 17
year olds like fake ids
come on there's the people are faking
like their passport that's 100
yeah whatever like the [ __ ] bouncers
give a [ __ ]
yeah kidding me sure you could hand a
[ __ ] mcdonald's like 10 coffee card
to them as an idea i'd let you [ __ ]
in the club in the uk
to be fair to be fair though if any
country is probably
going to do like a fully normal concert
first it's going to be the us of the uk
with how they're going yeah i mean
whether they should
when they should yeah when they should
it's a different question but
i mean from what i've heard from like
like third-party information from
all my mates back there it's the one
thing that we've been doing well about
about the uh pandemic which is the
vaccine response right
which is just it kind of makes sense
it's pretty tragic though it's just like
us uk bought them all and then no one
else gets
it yeah exactly it's pretty tragic
really
yeah you know because you get it from
the inside of the club you're like yeah
we're doing great and then yeah
you see oh yeah of course how's the rest
of the world doing yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] attitude right
it's pretty tragic
money talks exactly exactly